gloria romano c'est l'inconnue la plus
célèbre du cinéma mondial
elle revient d'hollywood couverte de
lauriers de dollars à bridas jean à la
sofia la claudia voici la gloria ça pue
mécha vous dites peut pas être fait
comme ça je suis moche ces nouvelles de
nos positions n'ont fini tu agis foutu
la lumière qu'est ce que c'est cette
lumière c'est la police ou quoi coût
gloria romane où vous êtes blonde jolie
sensu el sissi après votre premier film
américain la presse internationale a
salué en vous une nouvelle marilyn loria
romane ou êtes-vous marilyn monroe à ça
commence pour les journalises la
terrible pourquoi la marilyn toujours
toujours toujours c'est déjà douze
femmes quelles sont les marilyn je suis
gloria nous sommes beaucoup des blondes
sur le monde
on vous a connu brume et ça change un
peu ça change un peu plus le ballon
c'est la vie je peux plus me regarder
avec les cheveux noirs tirés semble a
commenté delic et à cet animal que vous
mangez ici en france la grenouille
oui l'académie dont les maris le mari et
mari de la grille nous le crapaud et
j'ai dû avec vous comparez un crapaud
c'est du masochisme et qu est-ce qu ici
salek les les parle-moi convenable
on part affectée que je parle pas bien
un crapaud vous acceptez mes marilyn ça
ne semble pas vous enchanter quand vous
comparez la manche entre pas ça
m'enchante pas à lesquin dans les
canettes je suis italienne ce ton et
lili petit pois si les mouches
la marine s'est elle a alors ton c'est
très sexy cette mouche là je sais pas je
suis pas un homme c'est les hommes qui
parlent toujours sexy mais vous y pensez
vous accepté de tourner des scènes très
déshabillée j'accepte peur j'accepte 6e
si j'accepte pas je vais tout la ville
spaghettis à la bolognaise à mains nues
piaggio vespa get sa femme agressée pour
oui c'est gênant pour vous montrer tel
qu'on vous a vu dans votre dernier film
n'est pas moi qui avais sera doublé je
montre tout moi pourquoi tel que miyama
draine en elle c'est pas d'accord elle
dit comme ça que je suis encore une
petite bambine mega man est content vous
déshabiller devant une caméra c'est un
supplice pour vous c'est un supplice
ça dépend des photos un peu osée dans
les magazines c'est bien votre bac
aurait fils et moi si je veux saluer et
le photographier à la doublure c'est
elle qui passe aujourd'hui à la
télévision avec soit pas moi c'est la
vie tb notre tenue préférée pour dormir
j'ai déjà entendu ça oui moi je donne
avec un tee shirt et aussi avec les
pouces dans l'ère bush
hassan el hadi qui qui qui m'amena les
yeux montre d'une grande importance dans
votre vie m'a dit tiens c'est de toi tu
es bien la france et les français sont
obsédés les italiens ils sont obtenus
les américains et sont fatigués
dans un grand film italien ou défi vous
mais fait rire directrice tu m'as comme
au keirin on sait très bien qu'un homme
il vous est de marché nous en italie les
hommes à la la la sofia et lapentti
monique antonioni claudio cristallerie
giulietta fellini réglera rien qui maman
s'est mis l'argent on met la donne alors
je la prends c'est une femme gloria vous
allez je crois une enfance difficile
as tu veux parler ça l'enfance
maintenant à l'olp au coupe-coupe
maquilleuse anita aller à anita à annie
date
tu me souffle un peu de la main pour
faire pleurer un peu les yeux
babet à peine un peu à l agréable
ça tourne
d'où ma question noria vous allez je
crois une enfance difficile en italie
là bas les beti il demande à manger tous
les jours en italie
alors ma mère a prouvé la maman et papa
je n'avais pas des papas alors moi moi
jaune